the one where I'm not gonna pick because  they're two of my buddies uh is that  that's important Michael Chandler I'll  talk about the fight but you're that's  the only fight you're not getting a pick  on out of me  um it's gonna be a great fight that has  five Night written all over unless  Chandler was to land one of his big  bombs which is notoriously known for but  um you know for Chandler he's kind of  the OC's Golden Boy you know he was  hoping for a gigantic fight there's a  lot of talk you know pairing him up with  Connor there's all sorts of chatter  online about what his next fight was  going to be and he had a big one he got  a big fish on the line with that's  Emporium Man Legends so looking forward  to that fight